[Music]
today Los Angeles reached record low
temperatures in some areas in the low
30s
yeah when reached for comment the rest
of the country said just keep making TV
shows you [ __ ] it is hard to I mean I
grew up in Boston people like it's 58
how will we live yeah hard to call
people like in Chicago where it's 10
below wind chill and say like it got
down to 48 I had to eat my cat yeah many
residents of Los Angeles have been
completely unprepared for the bitter
cold yeah apparently Kim Kardashian wore
so many layers today people thought she
was Chloe always my favorite reactions
the gasps and then applause who watched
the Golden Globes last night a lot of
entertaining a lot of great moments a
lot of memorable moments enough you saw
Jodie Foster's speech during her
emotional speech last night Jodie Foster
said she was gay fifty and Friends with
Mel Gibson afterwards her publicist told
Jodie I'm gonna need a raise okay people
talking about about Mel Gibson
yeah the Golden Globes yeah he was there
yeah Mel Gibson attended to the Golden
Globes he sat front row center he was
nominated in the category most
uncomfortable sitting between the
Spielberg's and the Weinsteins
doesn't even seem like that should be a
category does it no seems more like a
monologue you know no please
did you see Tommy Lee Jones sitting in
the crowd
good god what the hell was that all
about
he was miserable no matter what anyone
did or said the guy would not laugh Alan
show that clip of Tommy Lee Jones Hope
Springs and Shia sassy sheriff sheriff
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like someone just told them Lincoln
was shot you know unbelievable what was
going on there now what else
President Obama is coming under a lot of
criticism that his new administration
has less diversity than his first one
that's what people were saying which is
why this morning Obama said all right
fine I am a Muslim okay
mix it up a little bit interesting
speaking of the president President
Obama's half-brother is running for
political office in Kenya yeah
Donald Trump has already accused him of
being born in the United States there's
a new
[Music]
[Applause]
come on Tommy Lee this will get AB
laughing I didn't think that would work
what else there's a new app that's
coming out that shows you how alcohol
will aid you yeah when I was a kid we
did this by looking at our father poor
dad doesn't drink but I'll throw under
the bus for Laughs so I mean Lee like
you know what else gonna hey this
interesting over the weekend the Miss
America pageant was won by a woman from
Brooklyn Brooklyn yes she was the first
winner to stroll down the runway and say
hey I'm walking here
[Applause]